always thrilled having him back here on
the rich eisen show in a wednesday spot
which he uh
he answered the bell every week during
the regular season and kind enough to do
so during the
postseason as well from good morning
football and his podcast
ten questions with kyle brandt on
spotify and ringer kyle brandt how are
you kyle happy new year brother
happy new year to you too rich i'm great
it is such a small portion of the year
that we get football this exciting
not as small as duffo on the youtube
picture
nice all the small nonetheless well done
well done everybody
um so uh do we know who came up with
super wild card weekend
do we know who came up with with that
super rich it
sounds like somewhere where you would
have a microphone giving away cash and
prizes
hey everybody it's just a third weekend
it's time to play some super wild card
action
well actually the way the way i i
mentioned is i i everything goes back to
looney tunes for me the way you know
wally
coyote's super wild card weekend that's
the way i'm going to be saying it from
now on
even though it might happen with the uh
i said i said i said a super wild card
[Laughter]
listen to me when i'm talking to you
with six playoff games
that's exactly what we got this weekend
and uh i'm gonna jump straight in
kyle i'm gonna jump straight in right to
the third rail here
um because i know you were you were
saying you were not buying the
trubisky renaissance you were not buying
the the fact that
trubisky and um and and matt nagy and
ryan pace were just being them it's now
be
the be you uh backed in uh
to the playoffs but with three nice
games before
taking the packers into a fourth quarter
competitively
um they're they're in the playoffs
because of that do you buy this do you
do you like it you you think this is the
future for your team or what trying
i'm trying to be positive in 2021 rich i
think we also i'm trying to be positive
i'm trying to get a foothold on how the
bears could win this game i'm racking my
brain
okay even down to the point where the
finest moment for the chicago bears
organization took place in the new
orleans superdome in january of 1986
when they won the super bowl they're
going back to the
scene of that but that's where i'm at
i'm scraping by from 35 years ago um
what's killing me is to really get into
the game is
roquan smith might not play in this game
he's banged up
left the packers game has an elbow
injury if he does not play
i i think alvin kamara might have 13
touchdowns it might be that bad
because he is so important and the
reason they drafted roquan smith is to
play games in domes against really fast
offenses and go sideline to sideline
if they don't have him i feel like it's
just going to be released to hounds for
the guys with the fleur-de-lis
and as as it pertains to mitch it's this
classic
syndrome of the worst thing you can be
as an nfl quarterback
is decent it you just be bad
or be great like please don't be decent
because then we don't know what to do
with you
and it's just it was a classic
trubisky's the most difficult boyfriend
to break up with ever
because at the second you he makes a
mess of himself he shows up with roses
and diamonds and that was the winning
streak to end the season
and then we got the packers so it's such
a difficult hellish purgatory to be in
which doesn't really make sense but
that's what trubisky is hellish
purgatory
well i think the the the silver lining
in all this
uh tell me why you know here well here
it is is that you know while you're
still wondering
is this uh fugazi trubisky or
real trubisky and and a decision is
going to have to be made
um and i do think the answer is let him
hit the free agent market and then sign
him at a
a cut rate after his market value is
determined
um if he's up for that um or
move on and that said we can figure that
out for another day though
but david montgomery is a real thing
though i think that's oh my god
i think i think that's been determined
that you were hoping for that last year
didn't materialize led to a disastrous
season and the fact that the run game
was allowed
to balance things out you know in a way
that
we're we're still waiting to see if the
bills could do such a thing and they
might not need it
you know what i'm saying like that we're
seeing montgomery showed and he could
take you home
in a playoff game the way that he's been
playing that's that's
at least the good stuff i think with the
defense that you clearly will bring into
the next season
as well i think so too listen the
montgomery thing
it got lost because the packers blew
their doors off in the second half
because rogers is rogers but
that bears packers game started
beautifully the bears
had one of the best drives they've had
all season montgomery's going right
between the guards he's gashing the
packers
he got hurt for a second went out and
they lost all their momentum they lost
everything but they
found something in him now are they
going to be able to hang in the dome
i hate the matchup i do as a bears
enthusiast i was hoping for anybody
they can muck it up with play outside
even tampa i don't care i just don't
want to be in 72 degrees
astro turf that's not the way the bears
are built it's
trubisky to allen robinson for 12 yards
and montgomery for three yards it's just
it's a terrible terrible match-up and
look they've lost the debris during the
nagi era they've lost the bridgewater
during the naggy area if you want to say
they're due they're due
and i just wish rich having come on your
show all season long as a chicago native
i could say one bleeping thing positive
about the bears i feel like i'm such a
downer about the bears
but they betrayed me they betrayed you
by you know losing six games in a row
and and i guess making the playoffs but
now here i'm supposed to be like you
know what rich we made it we're in
i i can't say they're going to beat the
saints i love upsets this weekend i do
so then let's get it to that one let's
get to the poll question then uh
christopher
since kyle brandt likes polk upsets that
is our that is the subject of our at
rich eisen show
twitter housed poll question go for it
yeah buddy who's got the best chance to
pull off these super wild cards
super wild card okay browns it's a great
poll question browns
colts titans home dogs or the washington
football team
okay here's i think that one of the
people who was
most upset of which there are millions
of people
upset about nate sudfeld coming in for
the philadelphia eagles
i think one who was secretly upset about
it was tom brady
because if i'm tom brady i'm like
pleased for the love of god
let let the let the the giants in even
if the cowboys would let them in
i don't want to face those guys on the
washington line
if you're 43 years old and you look
you think you want to run away from
those guys for a whole night even
even their names are terror these are
these are guys named
chase chase swept and pain that sounds
like every middle-aged guy's nightmare
and that's what tom brady has to face
actually just here you can flip the
table maybe
that's the one i'm hoping for because i
think it would be the most shocking
awesome exactly
talk about middle-aged nightmares just
hearing those names made me want to pee
in the middle of the night real thing
but you're not wrong though middle of
the night urination uh
get off your phone when are you going to
be home they have all the players named
that all the things we dread
you know chase young said he wanted
brady too uh you know
and then uh ariens is like it could be
one of those be careful what you wish
for
uh and and and washington's defense um
they they they give you no yak they they
hit you and they put you right down
right away it's
very very rare that you get one of those
30-yard gains because the last 25 yards
are
are due to a missed tackle or a missed
assignment they're really
they're really poised um so you're
you're choosing washington football team
in this poll question
right now um with an asterisk yes i
i know that there's a poll question
you're supposed to choose one rich
i i really really like cleveland and
i know what's going on and i know it's
not pretty and i know covet
is a vicious bastard and i hate the
timing and we know the story of the joel
betonios and
all the years it's been since these guys
have gotten in i like cleveland
um i read a piece this morning by mary
kay cabot
that i thought was unbelievable and it
detailed the
mission that kevin stefanski has been on
since march
to say that this wrath is coming and
we are not going to blink we are going
to be the team that doesn't blame it on
it that does not
make excuses because of how this affects
us and they've been through
so much already massive injuries
covet affecting miles garrett for two
games the cove fiasco
against the jets the steelers win i
think this
team has an identity of bring it on we
will make us stronger
and uh i really really like cleveland
this weekend i know it's nuts and i know
up against a lot
and not having the head coach and the
play caller and all that stuff i don't
think pittsburgh is that great
and in a roundabout way between the ears
psychologically motivationally
what has transpired in the last 48 hours
might actually be a good thing for
cleveland in terms
i think it's going to light the craziest
fire they've ever had now
that is a heck of a take um and
one one that is in the realm of
possibility no question about it
um because as you know in the nfl
adversity
is uh initially absorbed and then
uh eventually attempted to be turned
into opportunity sometimes though the
adversity is too much
like say having the wrong play call
dialed up
uh just as tj watt is turning somebody
into a turnstile
and you know that that that can't be
avoided as
as much as defense you can download alex
van pelt with whatever he thinks he can
that can't be
avoided but the steelers were your
pre-season pick for the afc
what what do you think happened kyle
what do you think happened with this
team um
okay so i think that they got wildly
fatigued emotionally
physically they eventually ended up
losing on
a wednesday night it's a very strange
game
right and then i think there was
absurdity
where they were pissing teams off by
dancing on their logos and i don't think
that was trivial
i don't think that that was
inconsequential i think it played a huge
role in the momentum of the cincinnati
game
and um listen they can't
they cannot run the ball people are
screaming at pittsburgh
why don't you run the ball i don't
understand all the good steelers teams
can run
they can't they know they can't they've
tried and this is when i was terrified
about the pittsburgh steelers in the
playoffs it wasn't when they lost i
don't care if they lose they never
thought they'd win all their games i
don't even thought they'd go 13-3
they had a goal line sequence a couple
of weeks ago where they had a first and
goal
and they ran the ball and they got
absolutely stuffed and the rest of the
plays they ran on the one yard line from
the shotgun
and i'm like this team can't win the
super bowl you can't do that and
your receivers aren't that good they're
not good enough to win a super bowl when
you run shotgun plays on the one yard
line
that's when i was worried about them
emotionally they've been through some
some stuff and physically they it's not
that they don't run
they can't and you can't win like that i
hear you the name
josh dobbs has been bandied about this
week too uh that that one is
because i i find that fascinating i
don't know how you get him on the field
um and i don't know how you get them on
the field to provide the the rushing
which is what uh that's why i think
they'd put him on the field clearly it's
not to put him on the field to read
defenses
and and push the ball down the field
because obviously your first ballot hall
of famer is superior at that
but but but if you do have trouble
gaining yards
on the ground and you need to and you
need to open things up
what a fascinating name to be throwing
out there because he's
extremely talented i just don't know how
they put it together
like that they have to have some sort of
idea right kyle
yeah i mean you do the taste something
maybe
he's not taste them but he he does bring
his own thing there's a couple of things
this weekend rich like
where some big time head coaches are
going to have to make some crazy
decisions and
for tomlin it might be like you know
what take ben off the field
and then the one we've been batting
around a lot yeah is with mcveigh
and john wolford now the situation
becomes really easy if
goff can't go but we've been biting at
this apple that p
shreds has put out there a lot peter
streger who knows the rams really well
listen if jared goff is good to go
they're still not thrilled to play him
this weekend and
that wolford brings this kind of jalen
hurts in for carson wentz type energy
oh my i don't think it's a lock okay now
let's let's do this kyle cause this is
this is great
uh kyle brant here on the rich eisen
show mentioning about good morning
football
where you can see him and the rest of
the gang every day on nfl network at 7
a.m eastern time
okay i don't know which narrative that
i'm hearing
a lot about is crazier okay you tell me
the one you're touching on which is you
know i guess you got to go higher
register on this one
yeah maybe john wolf maybe john
walford's a better choice than jared
goff
okay okay and then this one's not even
being said higher register this one's
just being said
you know like this is the you know
gospel that uh
the the dolphins made the mistake of
taking tour with justin herbert sitting
out there that tour is essentially
useless
you know chan gayley just lost his job
today because he resigned a tour that
it too is the issue um and herbert is
you know he is all that plus biscuit but
i don't know which one's crazier that
that that two is already finished and
herbert
was the winner of that draft class
um in that choice or or what you're
talking about so i'll i'll give you the
floor
on what you think is more real
it's a that's a great this is a great
supplemental pull quest there you go
um there you go i i bit back at peter
hard
about the idea that john walford would
start
over uh a green lit jared goff
i mean listen i'm not a jared goff
enthusiast
i'm not even sure there is one
i think he is the hummus of nfl
quarterbacks it's just fine
it gets the job done it's never going to
blow your hair back it's going to be
fine
um but jay goff is is one of the nfc
title game
in the superdome jared goff just this
year has beaten a bunch of these teams
in the playoff field like
he's he i understand he's not exciting
but to roll out someone from the arizona
hot shots
who literally didn't score a touchdown
last week there's all this revisionist
history about what wolford did against
the terrible arizona cardinals defense
he didn't score a touchdown he had nine
points the rams defense had nine points
so i think any any uh storyline that
says
you never know mcveigh's crazy it's his
team he may roll with the hot hand
the hand is not that hot i think he'd be
nuts to do that
and if jared goff didn't start in a
scenario in which the doctors say he can
and they said they said we're going with
john wolford
i would immediately demand a trade if i
was jared goff and say i'm out of here
you don't believe me you're gonna start
the hot shot over me
no i think the belief in golf is much
higher
in their building than then i hope then
well i i think it is i i really believe
it is you know and
and um you know i guess if he's the
hummus that would make what mcveigh the
the celery stick that is the delivery
method of the hummus i don't know you
know you dip it one of those little
carrots
pretzel chips okay very good but
you know and then i i i you can't you
you know you can't put john walford
against jamal adams where you where
jamal adams doesn't even know where he's
coming from but the the arizona hot
shot's going to figure that out pre-snap
what to do i mean not not a shot not not
not not a shot
on planet earth i don't think but what
do you think so are you saying
what how do you view the narrative of of
herbert over to a
case closed that's it next case what
about that
um two ahead maybe the weirdest rookie
season
a long time from a quarterback and i
remember i think it was the third
quarter of that game
i was already seeing people online
saying that the dolphins need to draft
the quarterback
next year right crazy no i i've been a
massive
tour enthusiast massive um just for what
he's been through his ability i think it
was
a disastrous as worse as a week 17 could
get and he was terrible and if fitz had
been healthy in that
game i think flores might have put him
in after one series no doubt
at least might have been that short
first quarter we would have seen him in
the first quarter
for sure is that where you have it first
quarter oh yeah oh you could see the way
that was working
you could see the way that was working
you know um but
but i can't i can't say no to a control
out delete we're reset we're done
and listen herbert i i'm not sure
herbert's going to be joe montana either
i don't know if he's going to be the
best in the class joey burrow was really
really good when he got hurt so no i'm
not jumping to any of those conclusions
i'm still going to double back and say
the wolford take is way crazy
before i let you go you know i know
you're a big pop culture guy as well we
came up with a
a a a pop culture reference for for josh
allen
kyle okay i can't wait all right what do
you got he's the mandalorian
at quarterback oh that's perfect he just
stands there in his armor
keeps his helmet on until the job's done
and he'll never you know and this is the
way
he just stands there and just destroys
every everyone in front of him
uh we've we we figured out cole beasley
as baby yoda
uh if you really want to keep on
expanding this an analogy
um but he's the man he's the mandalorian
he's just he just
stands back there and he'll take the
shots he'll take the hits but that armor
is
impenetrable and and and
he will he will take uh what is it in
front of him to complete the mission
what do you like about that is excellent
all right oh look at that we even put up
we even put the helmet on
as the uh as the gina carano uh
warrior with the huge firepower the
acquisition that the mandalorian makes
in the middle of the season that he
needs more firepower yes
that um i think that uh right now this
weekend
that would make uh phillip rivers the uh
giancarlo esposito
yeah he's the maf gideon he's the moff
gideon
yep absolutely uh i don't want to go too
deep anywhere for any spoiler alert but
i really really like it uh and he has
he's in possession now of the dark saber
so it's it's that is the bill's offense
the dark saber we had
we had another one uh rich that's really
related to that
we're talking about how there's 7 000
ish bills fans are going to be allowed
yes the first time in the game and that
i think that with all these years and
all this deprivation they've had this
year
the 7 000 bills fans are the equivalent
of
70 000 uh other teams fans it is like
they said that 300 spartans were like 10
000 other men
when they were united in their
fierceness so i think the seven thousand
bills fans are the 300 spartans as they
watch the mandalorians well i don't know
how they're going to handle the crowd
um and allow them you know uh in the
state how they're going to allow them in
the stadium or in the parking lot but
wherever the perimeter is there will be
a table and someone will jump on it and
it will be on fire
and the people you know at le you know
it's a one o'clock eastern game
so i guess the drinking starts at
midnight so here we go
and they can't be more fired up this is
going to be and it's a hell of a
match-up philip rivers
you know maybe in his last game of his
career potentially against josh allen
um and and the running game uh of the
colts trying to
slow down what the what the bills are
going to do and it's
frank reich of all people that can won
and dumb this team
in their in their big moment um first
time
since you know uh frank was on the team
um
last time frank was on the team last
time they won 13 games
i mean that's why it's a super wild card
weekend
kyle literally super super wild card
weekend i'm very much me too forward to
seeing
the mandalorian i think rich on the
first play from scrimmage is going to
call go in the huddle
and call the deep shot to diggs and say
this is the play
this is the play i like it look we're
workshopping it we're workshopping it
go go forth and use that on good morning
football kyle we'll look forward to
tomorrow morning my man excellent
uh well we'll see you tomorrow morning
and uh and when your pod comes back
in action later this month or when do we
get next couple of weeks we're actually
lining up
our personnel now and we will come back
surging ten questions
it's awesome it's a game show it's a
talk show it's all the stuff that you
and i love rich people love it i hate to
i hate to reveal it uh kyle brandt's uh
first guest
on 10 questions with uh with kyle brent
nate sudfield is going to be his first
guest
coming on because we're going to go with
jalen
you like doug peterson you just want to
see what you got nate sutfeld and uh
and and that's it that's that's the way
you roll the integrity of the pod rich
thanks for the call kyle we'll chat soon
of course let's see
don't know the one and only kyle brown
buddy hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here